hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es wieder eine motiv tore von
uns und zwar habe ich ja diese filmreihe
mal gestartet und macht gerne film
rezepte und dieses mal haben wir eine
torte zum film sieht man doch an den
roten köpfe an dem polit und anderen
fraport er wird diese leckere torte
gebacken und die sieht nicht nur außen
toll aus sondern auch innen
denn im inneren versteckt sich eine
überraschung wenn man die torte nämlich
auf schneidet dann hat sie so ein
schachbrettmuster und da kommen auch
noch süßigkeit heraus und ja ich mag den
film immer ganz gerne früher habe ich
den auch schon geguckt den gab es auch
schon zu meiner zeit und samira cook die
serie auch ganz gerne
aber mittlerweile gibt es auch gerade
den kinofilm und zwar läuft er schon
seit gestern in den kinos und ich mag
den film sehr gerne weil er in dieser
hauptcharakter also dieser chipmunk mich
immer total anders stimme los
erinnert ihr euch an die große
entdeckung an die verfügung
bleib auf dieser seite des bettes die
turbulente momente wie sie zu einer
familie machten
die chipmunks werden erwachsen
du kleiner schlawiner ständig in den
bank doch dann passiert etwas erwartet
nichts für ungut winter fährt mit mir
doch marie ihr werdet euch super
verstehen ist der sekundenkleber 36
deshalb machen sie sich auf die reise zu
wasser und in der luft was ist das nur
für ein freund aufbewahrt aber sie sind
nicht allein unterwegs
ich bin die polizei diesen januar
ernsthaftem no fly liste
ich dachte ihr erwachsen genug um auf
euch selbst sind die chipmunks jetzt
gehts euch an den kragen
man möchte ja rasch wieder im kino
alvin und die chipmunks auf eine ruhige
nacht
partikel
gott sei dank ist eine stimme wieder
okay und ich zeige euch gleich wie man
diese torte macht und am ende des videos
gibt's noch ein kleines gewinnspiel und
zweites video in kooperation mit
twentieth century fox germany entstanden
und die haben wir ein paar gewinne zur
verfügung gestellt die ich an euch
verlosen darf und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach einfach wir wollen diese torte
backen
nein so nicht in ordnung
ich habe ziel bereits was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich zwei mal meinen
lockeren teig gebacken für motiv torten
und habe den eben eingefärbt in rot und
gelb
und da habe ich es jeweils eine portion
genommen und habe die dann in diesem
edelstahl ihm selbst hören schüssel
gebacken und die habe ich vorher mit
back transfer eingefädelt und dann noch
etwas vermählt und ich hatte etwas mehr
zeit übrig und habe die reste einfach in
einer anderen form gebacken aber an den
teig heruntergerechnet dabei hat ein
bisschen zu wenig gewesen
deswegen habe ich jetzt zwei portionen
jetzt nämlich schon mal den ersten tag
die habe ich die bereits gestern
gebacken und habe sie einfach bei
zimmertemperatur abgedeckt stehen lassen
man kann es wird besser schneiden so
jetzt nehme ich hier meine torten säge
und stellen sie ein und schneidet dann
die schichten
und um jetzt diesen caro effekt zu
erzielen nehme ich jetzt eine scheibe
gelb eine scheibe brot und eine scheibe
geld noch mal oben drauf und jetzt muss
sich der ringe ausstechen also es kennt
ihr vielleicht auch von meiner
regenbogen torte mit dem
schachbrettmuster und jetzt habe ich
hier zwei größen an ausstellern mal
gefunden
wenn jetzt keine ausgeharrt könnte auch
teller und gläser nehmen und das ebenso
ausstechen bzw ausschneiden
es stellt sich das gut aus
und jetzt setzt sich den ersten gelben
ring mal auf eine platte und die klebe
diesem kuchen klebe ich das noch nicht
fest denn ich muss es später nochmal
umdrehen also jetzt noch nicht an der
platte fixieren hier innen streiche ich
jetzt eine schicht ghana schreien und
zwar wichtig auch schon gestern
vorbereitet und die ganzen rezepte die
findet ihr übrigens in der infobox
verlinkt da hab ich nämlich die basic
rezepte bereits dazu gedreht
da kommt jetzt der rotering rein
und den mittleren ring setzte ich jetzt
nicht rein dann steige ich jetzt hier
eine schicht ghana strüber
dann kommt der zweite ring drauf und
jetzt droht also jetzt immer abwechselnd
einfach schichten
so die torte zusammengesetzt und jetzt
muss ich sie ganz kurz von der
tortenplatte runter nehmen weil ich
tortenplatte zurechtschneiden möchte da
könnte es entweder eine charta platte
nehmen so eine leicht schaum platte oder
ihr nehmt einfach zum beispiel einen
karton das geht auch und damit ich weiß
wie groß ich dem schneiden muss nämlich
jetzt ein lebensmittel stift und war
einfach drum herum
jetzt kann ich die torte einmal kurz von
der platte unternehmen und habe jetzt
hier im innern auch dieses freie fach
da kommen nämlich gleich die süßigkeiten
aber jetzt schneide ich erstmal die
platte zu recht
und hier hinten scheine ich jetzt noch
so ein kleines rundes stück weg und zwar
für diese öffnung hier also ich sehe
jetzt auch eigentlich hier die mütze ist
genauso groß wie die schüssel sehen habe
ich auch die schüssel genommen und das
mache ich jetzt einfach mit hilfe eines
ausstellers oder ihr könnt zum beispiel
einfach ein glas benutzen
jetzt will ich ihnen die ersten worte
einfach ein paar süßigkeiten rein
dadurch drohten gelbe dann streichen sie
etwas ganache drauf damit die platte
jetzt auch gleich am kuchen haften
bleibt
das kommt die platte draus
jetzt muss ich nur noch hinten diese
öffnung wegschneiden
und jetzt 30 die erste schicht kanal
strom herum stellt die torte für etwa 15
minuten in den kühlschrank und streicht
sie dann komplett glatt
wie
er zählte torte noch im kühlschrank und
jetzt kann ich schon mal den überzug
vorbereiten und darf habe ich mich jetzt
für von land und modelliert schokolade
entschieden und hpc zwei päckchen von
dort und zwei pkw modelle schokolade und
knete sitzt schön zusammen
und zwar habe ich dann einfach den
vorteil dass ich so von der modelliert
schokolade diesen tollen schokoladigen
geschmack habe aber eben auch vom
fondant so diese konsistenz also das
weichere und damit lässt sich dann eben
super arbeiten
jetzt ist der front und dem modell
schokolade weich und gut vermischt und
jetzt rolle ich das auch etwas becker
stärke aus
jetzt könnt ihr den von hand nehmen und
drüber ausrollen und jetzt 30 ihn von
oben nach unten glatt und dann müsste
einfach die ränder mit einem marzipan
messer wegnehmen
und jetzt nämlich ein stück von land und
taucht es so ein bisschen in becker
stärke denn dann kann ich jetzt die
torte damit glätten
mit einem normalen blätter bildete
selbst nicht gut funktionieren weil wir
keine gerade flächen haben sondern eine
halbkugel
und jetzt muss ich hier noch die nähte
und diese ganzen streifen hier markiert
und das mache ich jetzt erstmal mit
einem minimal
und dann fahr ich linie noch mal mit
seiner mutter ihr werkzeug nah
mit einem trikotwechsel kann ich jetzt
die naht andeuten
aus einem kleinen stück verdammt form
ich jetzt noch diesen knüppel da oben
und dem klebe ich jetzt mit etwas zucker
kleber an
und jetzt muss ich noch diese löcher
hier markieren die diese käppis da oben
haben
deswegen habe ich einfach so ein kleines
stück backpapier damit jemand den
gleichen abstand von dem knüppel da oben
habe das leben ist ihr dran und dann
kommt mit ich mit so einem cache
popstars jetzt
jetzt stehe ich mit einer spritztour
noch kleine kreise aus und die kommen
dann da noch mit drauf
jetzt müsste nur noch mit diesem cape
aufstieg des aufstiegs
dann kommt da ein bisschen kleber drauf
und dann wird es da drauf geklebt
als nächstes mache ich jetzt vorne
dieses schild und dafür nehme ich
einfach die auch das original käppi als
vorlage und mal einmal drumherum
brauchen lebensmittel stift
märz es hier einfach kurz ans käppi
angepasst und es passiert und jetzt kann
ich nochmal kronland ausrollen
jetzt muss ich die schablone zweimal
ausschneiden einmal genau in der größe
und einmal etwas größer
und wenn dieses pack stück zwischen die
zwei sonderschichten kleben und zwar wie
der vordere teil sowieso nicht gegessen
also dieses schild würde man ähnlich
essen da steckt ja kein kuchen mit drin
und damit ich einfach etwas stabilität
habe dass ich den karton mit drin
wenn ihr aber ganz viel zeit habt könnt
ihr das auch so trocknen lassen über
zwei drei tage und es dann an kleben
wobei ich so einfacher finde vor allem
sollte es noch flexibel sein damit wir
es gleich noch richtig passend an leben
können und dafür nehme ich wieder etwas
kleber und den streich jetzt großflächig
da drauf
dann schneide ich das hier noch mal am
rand weg
und die offenen rendert die klebe jetzt
noch mal zusammen und drückt die rennen
dazu und schneit einfach nochmal
drumherum
die
jetzt lege ich hier auch etwas
backpapier über dieses käppi ihr könnt
auch über was anderes zu überlegen
einfach damit so ein bisschen eine form
bekommt
und jetzt mache ich davon auch das
typische a für die alvin mütze neben
dafür weiße modelle schokolade und färbt
sie jetzt mit lebensmittelfarbe passte
in gelb ein
jetzt mache ich noch hinten den
verschluss deswegen haben hier nochmal
roth ausgerollt und wenn es jetzt so
langen streifen ausschneiden nochmal
prägen und anlegen
ich
hier markiere ich jetzt noch ein paar
feinheiten mit dem cuttermesser
b
und jetzt fehlt nur noch der schriftzug
da hinten und da könnte jetzt einfach
etwas alkohol oder etwas palmen flüssig
machen und mit etwas zucker vermischen
und damit gut deckend ist möchte ich
jetzt weiß mit etwas geld
die torte ist jetzt fertig entwickeln
sie anschneiden ok samira bist du schon
gespannt ist meine stimme ich will noch
mal 200 zu ertragen
und
meinst du probleme der papa probleme und
fahrten ist es natürlich richtig cool
mit dem karo muster bei mir als katholik
aber was so eine krise das ist eine
weiße schokoladen ja ja und ich finde
sie sieht einfach toll aus wenn man sie
auftreten hat einfach dieses schöne karo
muster was farblich so der mütze passt
und jetzt am iran sollen wir noch das
gewinnspiel zeigen mit gibt ja noch was
zu gewinnen und war g2 erinnern des
romans fanpakete bestehend aus folgendem
und zwar zwei artikel hat die familie ja
schon an
zeig mal kurz ein pullover und zwar geht
es den pullover in größe m also das
geschützte samira bisschen zu groß bei
ersteren kleid und dieses käppi und dazu
gibt es noch jeweils ein mikrofon genau
du kannst mal zeigen wie das
funktioniert da kann man als singen und
da kommt ein bisschen musik machte die
ganze mit dr
und dann gibt noch zwei kinokarten und
ein großes erinnerte chipmunks poster
wirksam
und alles was ihr völkers voraus mit
vollgas voraus und alles was ihr dazu
turm ist erstmal mikro aus genau
alles was sie dazu tun müsst ist
folgende frage vom rad zu beantworten
das steht noch eine frage überlegt ja
und zwar wie heißt der vater von dave
wie heißt der vater von lehrerin walsh
sagen dann frage ich euch wie heißt der
schlauste von den drei chipmunks es
nicht murat und er hat nicht noch genau
und dann könnt ihr gerne die kommentare
und infobox reinschreiben innerhalb von
einer woche werden mit an den gewinnen
die zwei gewinner ermitteln und euch
dann schriftlich benachrichtigen
genau dann bekommt ihr die gewinn pakete
zugeschickt gerne und wenn ihr gerne
diese torte nach machen wollt geht auf
salehs - blog.de doch stehen noch mal
die genommen zutatenangaben und gesehen
uns das nächste mal wieder und wünsche
wir verraten es nicht wir verraten
nichts der insider
da wird die torte zu
gesetz und jetzt trägt sie um denn ich
möchte da noch ein paar süßigkeiten
einfüllen und deswegen habe ich auch die
mittlere schicht eben nicht rein gesetzt
sondern habe die öffnung dagelassen
muratow kann schon mal die bonbons rüber
geben
ach super fast weg gemacht
ich glaube sie runter gerutscht